From the earliest steam machines to modern
muscle cars, engines have long powered engineering.
I mean, the field is literally named after
them.
Engines provide us with energy we can use for
all kinds of things, and how to optimize them is
one of engineering’s central problems.
One of the keys to solving it is the concept of
reversibility: the more reversible a system is, the
less work it needs from its surroundings.
In other words, a more reversible system needs
less fuel to keep going.
So if you’re trying to build the best engine
you can, reversibility is a good place to start.
[Theme Music]
Engines drive our society and many of the
machines we use every day.
And what’s inside many of our engines, are
pistons.
Pistons are disks or cylindrical parts that
move back and forth in a cylinder against
a liquid or a gas.
In an internal combustion engine, like the
one that’s under the hood of most cars,
the pistons are pushed by the expanding gases in
the cylinder, which turns a type of shaft or wheel.
This turns their repetitive, linear motion
into a rotation that helps power the engine.
When you’re dealing with a simple machine or
mechanism, like a piston, there are two main types
of energy you can put into or take out of the system:
heat and work.
You probably have a pretty good idea of what heat is.
Simply put, it’s thermal energy.
It’s what you feel when you step out in
the sun or stand by a warm fire.
In engineering, we define heat with the letter
Q.
Work, represented by the letter W, is a little
more complex.
It’s essentially any type of energy other
than heat that crosses into a system.
One way to measure it is by how much force
is being applied over a distance.
There are a different types of work you’re likely
to encounter as an engineer, but with all of them,
the idea is that by putting work into a system,
you can get some work out of it, usually in a more
useful form.
One type is pressure-volume work.
This has to do with the expansion and compression
of matter.
Squeezing a stress ball is a good example.
Based on how much pressure you apply to the
ball, the change in volume tells you how much
work you were able to achieve.
When the stress ball is expanded, we’d say the
work is negative, because it’s being done by the ball.
When it’s compressed, the work is positive,
because it’s being done on the ball.
Pistons involve pressure-volume work, too.
In a car, for example, the work done on the
system comes from the fuel, which heats up
gas in the cylinder when it’s ignited.
As the gas expands, it does work, with the
increased pressure pushing the piston up.
Then the gas cools again and the piston moves
back down.
This cycle produces work that turns the shaft
or wheel.
Another type of work is shaft work, which
is when a shaft or propeller rotates through
a liquid or gas.
There’s also electrical work, which is the work
done on a charged particle by an electric field.
You can think of it like the discharge from
a battery.
As you’re watching this video, there's electrical
work going on in your phone or computer.
A lot of engineering is about optimizing your
machines and processes to produce the most
amount of work with as little input as possible.
The more work a machine uses up, the more you
need to get out of it, to have it be worth your while.
It’s like a job; the more time and effort you put in,
the more you’ll want to get paid.
That’s why work is well...work.
With machines, optimizing work is all about
reversibility.
You’ll never get more energy out of a system
than what was put into it.
That would violate conservation of energy.
But if a process is reversible, that means
it can go back to its initial state and start
over with no additional work input.
In other words, when a process is reversible,
you’re maximizing the amount of work you
get for your input.
But reversible processes are impossible in
real life.
They require slow, steady, incredibly small changes
to make sure you don’t permanently change the
system in a way that you can’t reverse without
putting some additional work in.
Which...would require an infinite amount of
time.
So in the real world, all processes involving
work are irreversible.
They can be reset, to some extent, but you
need to put in a bit of elbow grease to get
them there.
A reversible process is more like the
best-case scenario – one you can get close to,
but never actually reach.
In engineering, it’s not so much about whether
a process is reversible, but how reversible it is.
The closer you can get to reversibility, the
more efficient and optimal the process will be.
To see what I mean, let’s go back to that
piston.
You want the piston to move up and down in
the cylinder, to turn a crank, and generate power.
There’s also gas in the cylinder.
Bringing the piston up expands the gas and
pushing it down compresses the gas.
When the gas is under compression, it will
expand on its own.
But it won’t compress again unless a force
is applied to it.
It’s like the stress ball – after you squeeze it,
it will expand back to its original size.
But the ball won’t randomly crumble back
in on itself without an outside force.
Say this piston is designed so the force compressing
the piston comes from a brick.
When you remove the brick, the gas below
the piston will expand will expand freely, and
the piston will rise.
But to get the gas to compress again and the
piston to go back down, you need to lift the brick
to put it back on top of the piston.
Since the system needs outside work to get it
back to where it was, with the gas compressed,
this process is irreversible.
Next, let’s say you trying to break the
brick in two.
The system starts out like before, with the
gas compressed by the weight of a full brick.
Then you remove one half-brick, leaving it
right where the piston was, near the bottom
of the cylinder.
The gas still expands, but it doesn’t push the
piston as far, since there’s still half a brick’s
worth of weight holding it down.
Then you remove the other half-brick, and like the
first one, you leave it at the same height, let’s say on
a shelf right next to the piston or something.
This allows the gas to expand as much as it
did when you were using one brick, pushing
the piston all the way up.
But, think about the amount of work it will
take to reverse this process and get the piston
to go back down.
Before, you had to lift the entire brick all the way
from where the piston started to where it stopped
when the gas was done expanding.
But this time, half the brick is already part
of the way up the cylinder, because that’s
where you removed it.
So you start by lifting that half-brick up to
the top, which compresses the gas and pushes
the piston part of the way down.
Then, you lift the other half-brick to where
the piston is now, pushing the piston down
all the way back to where it started.
So, instead of having to lift the whole brick all the
way up the piston, now you effectively only have to
lift half a brick all the way up the piston;
it just took two steps instead of one.
That’s a lot less work, which means the
process is that much less irreversible than
it was with one brick.
And now you can start problem-solving as an
engineer.
If breaking the brick in two makes the process
more reversible, how can you make it even better?
A simple answer is to keep breaking the brick
into smaller and smaller pieces.
Eventually, you’d turn it into infinitely
tiny grains of sand.
This time, you start with a pile of sand with
the same weight as the full brick, pushing
the piston down.
Then you remove one grain of sand at a time,
leaving each grain at the same height that the
piston was when you removed it.
Gradually, the piston rises, producing work.
But each movement is so small that to reverse
the process and move the piston down, all you really
have to do is shift each grain of sand sideways.
Remember, we’re talking about increments
that are infinitely small, so you effectively
aren’t lifting anything.
You can keep the shifting grains of sand sideways,
and slowly, the weight on the piston will increase,
compressing the gas and bringing you
right back to where you started.
Which is definitely less work than lifting
a whole brick, or even a half brick.
In fact, apart from that one grain you’ve
lifted from the bottom to the top,
the amount of work required to put each grain of
sand back on the piston is exactly the same as the
work ‘produced’ when you take it off.
Everything is happening so slowly and gradually that
you aren’t losing energy as heat, which means you
don’t need to ‘add’ work to replace that lost energy.
So you don’t need to put in any external
work to push the piston back down,
and you can use the same amount of work
produced by the system to get it right back to
where it started.
And there you have it: a reversible process.
Again, this would be pretty much impossible
to accomplish in real life.
For one thing, you can’t actually have infinitely
tiny grains of sand.
Even a single molecule isn’t infinitely
tiny.
Plus, you’d need an infinite amount of time
to get through all these infinitely small steps.
But as you break the brick into smaller pieces,
you can get closer and closer.
It’s also worth noting that the closer you
get to the reversible version of this process,
the longer it will take, which would not be
useful for most applications.
If this type of piston was in the engine of
your car, you’d be better off walking.
So reversibility sounds good, but you need
to work with irreversible systems if you really
want to achieve something.
As an engineer, the goal is to figure out how
close you can get a system to being reversible,
while still keeping it time, effort, and cost
effective.
Which brings us to efficiency.
In general, the efficiency of any system is
the ratio of what you get out of it, compared
to what you have to put into it.
It’ll have a value ranging from 0% to 100%,
with 100% being maximum efficiency.
In this case, efficiency helps quantify how
close a system is to perfectly reversible.
It’s the amount of work produced by
the system you’re looking at,
as a percentage of the amount of work that
would be produced by the ideal — but impossible
— reversible system.
The result is η, the efficiency.
If something is 100% efficient, that means
it’s a completely reversible system.
If it has 0 efficiency, it’s totally
irreversible.
You can see how important efficiency is by
going back to cars and engines.
The more efficient your vehicle is, the more
energy you can get out of your fuel, and the
farther you can go on a tank of gas.
That’s why you’ll want to keep efficiency
relatively high in most engineering systems.
It’s especially important whenever you
want to sustain a process for a long time,
like a cross-country road trip.
But sometimes you’ll need to sacrifice efficiency
to accomplish your goals.
You might need to put a lot of work into a
system to do something quickly or get a big output.
Think of a drag race.
Converting between types of energy might also be
more important than getting a big output for your input,
like turning a hand crank to get a small amount
of electricity when the power is out.
In these situations, converting energy might
be worth the low efficiency.
Engineering is all about trade-offs.
It’s awesome when you can have great
marks all around, but that’s probably not
going to happen very often.
In today’s lesson, we learned all about how to
design the most efficient machines and processes.
We began by going over heat and work: the
two main types of energy.
We then moved on to reversibility and
irreversibility and found that most processes
are somewhat irreversible in nature.
Putting all of this together, we worked through
a problem with a piston and learned how to use
efficiency to measure a system.
I’ll see you next time, when we’ll learn
about the first law of thermodynamics and the
conversation will really heat up.
Crash Course Engineering is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios.
You can head over to their channel to check
out a playlist of their amazing shows, like
PBS Space Time, Above the Noise, and Physics
Girl.
Crash Course is a Complexly production.
And this episode was filmed in the
Dr. Cheryl C. Kinney Studio with the help
of these wonderful people.
And our amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.